[Música]
volvemos ya con toda la economía aquí en
directo América de la mano de nuestro
compañero Luis Méndez que ya está aquí
listo con nosotros en el estudio y Luis
vamos a empezar hablando de la India
porque hay preocupación en torno al
crecimiento de la población y también
como consecuencia la reducción de las
mujeres en el ámbito laboral Así es
Rodrigo hay que contextualizar un poco
porque India actualmente registra una
población de
1418 millones de habitantes y se prevé
que pueda desplazar a China como el país
más poblado a finales del presente año
adicionalmente ya hablando
específicamente de la economía India es
una de las Naciones cuyo crecimiento
está entre los más rápidos Durante los
últimos años sin embargo todos estos
datos podrían simplemente ir en contra
del desarrollo de la mujer en el campo
laboral pues de acuerdo con diversos
análisis que son recogidos por una
publicación de la agencia de noticias ap
el país afrontó un desafío si no logra
garantizar que su población femenina
contabilizada en 70 millones de
habitantes no consigue empleo en medio
de este crecimiento demográfico según
los cálculos de la universidad
asinji sustentados en datos oficiales
durante el año 2004 un 35% de las
mujeres formaban parte de la tasa
laboral de la nación no obstante esta
cifra se redujo a un 25% en el año 2022
Pero estas cuentan con una limitante Y
es que guarda relación con que para las
autoridades si una mujer Trabaja al
menos una hora al día fuera del hogar
durante la semana anterior de recoger
las estadísticas ya entren las mismas
sin embargo el centro para el monitoreo
de la economía India genera que la cifra
de empleo entre las mujeres se ajusta un
10% durante el año 2022 y se prevé que
sigue disminuyendo la cifra realmente
baja Luis Pero me imagino que todo esto
se debe a una situación concreta
cuéntanos a cuál Rodrigo tiene que ver
con un ámbito cultural y es que para esa
sociedad la mujer sigue siendo vista
como el eje de funcionamiento del hogar
y de acuerdo con el texto de ap muchas
prefieren renunciar a sus trabajos
incluso ganando más que los hombres para
dedicarse por ejemplo Al cuidado de los
hijos escuchemos
ha habido una disminución en las tasas
de participación de las mujeres lo que
es preocupante porque da un mensaje muy
fuerte de que son las mujeres las que
cuidan una de las razones por la que las
mujeres tuvieron que dejar incluso estas
casas y raras oportunidades de empleo
por lo tanto necesitamos una economía de
cuidados para que las mujeres
permanezcan en el lugar de trabajo la
participación laboral de las mujeres en
India contribuye A menos del 20% del pib
repetimos preocupantes las cifras de
empleo en las mujeres en India vamos a
pasar a buenos datos para la economía
mundial porque parece que el Banco
Mundial prevé un crecimiento económico
global para este año 2023 Así lo anunció
te vi mal presidente de este organismo
durante la previa de las reuniones de
primavera que comenzarán el día de hoy
así revisó al alza el pronóstico de
crecimiento para este año de acuerdo con
malpas este será leve y se ubicará en un
2% pero brinca desde el 1,7% que fue
previsto en el informe presentado en
enero el sustento de este incremento se
debe una mejor perspectiva de
crecimiento para china que ahora se
ubica en un 5,1% para este año tu
economía personal sube o baja a Luis
está mantenida porque eso es importante
vamos ahora a Argentina porque hay
buenas noticias para el personal de
trabajo doméstico Así es de acuerdo con
la Comisión Nacional de trabajo de casas
particular es un organismo que depende
del Ministerio del trabajo en Argentina
se estableció que los trabajadores y las
trabajadoras de este sector recibieron
incremento en sus salarios de 27% para
los próximos tres meses el organismo
tripartito que integran el estado
representante de los empleadores y de
los sindicatos sector fijó el primero de
los aumentos en un 14% a partir del
presente mes en mayo el incremento será
de un 7%, no acumulativo al tiempo que
para el mes de junio recibirán un alza
del 6% dicho de otra manera para
aquellos empleados cuyo con retiro que o
aquellos que elaboran para un mismo
empleador el salario será de poco más de
400 dólares para el mes de abril
aquellos sin retiro o que trabajan con
varios empleadores su salario estará
alrededor de los 448 dólares
aproximadamente para el mes de abril
Bueno ahora vamos a ir con noticias
corporativas la empresa tesla que está
enfocada de todos en estos últimos meses
ha presentado hoy algunos anuncios que
anuncios han sido ha informado sobre la
construcción de una planta de baterías
en China específicamente en la localidad
de shanghái tesla fabricará la megapaca
que es una unidad de almacenamiento de
energía a gran escala en la nueva
instalación que se suma a la fábrica de
vehículos que ya está en Shanghai sobre
ello algunos medios sugieren que la
construcción podría comenzar para el
tercer trimestre del año y la producción
en Sí podría ser para 2024 no para de
crecer tesla pese a sus problemas en
algunos coches sobre todo con la
Inteligencia artificial Luis hay
indicadores de las bolsas Así es hubo
cierres mixtos en Asia en estos momentos
sobre todo porque tomaron con buenos
ojos lo que fueron los datos de empleo
presentados en Estados Unidos el pasado
día viernes en Japón y también en kospin
como es la bolsa de Corea del Sur
generaron crecimientos positivos a lo
largo de la jornada no así en Shanghai
que debido a esta tensión entre China y
Taiwán generó números negativos a lo
largo de la jornada y después de los
indicadores la cifra del día que traes
tiene que ver con los
423.384 empleos que fueron creados
durante el primer trimestre en México de
acuerdo con los datos del Instituto
Mexicano de los seguros sociales parece
que
relativamente buenos datos en América
Latina para la economía Luis Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros mañana